[Musik]
vorhang auf zum nächsten akt das teatre
dede sahen in paris lebt trotz omikron
wir haben weniger vorstellungen und
weniger zuschauer aber die die kommen
sind sehr enthusiastisch
nein nein wir haben keine angst für das
gebiet ist es unverzichtbar
weiterzumachen weiterzuleben
das geht schon ich hatte ja bereits
cobit mit geringen symptomen
das leben und das theaterspielen hand in
hand impfpass kontrolle im foyer
programm anpassung auf der bühne
einzelauftritte stadt truppe
achten darauf dass die schauspieler
nicht zur selben zeit auf der bühne
steht dass sie nacheinander auftreten es
steht meist eine person allein auf der
bühne das begrenzt die kontakte so haben
wir aufführungen die weitergehen können
in den verschiedenen kurven
frankreich improvisiert nicht nur auf
der bühne und es beginnt schon bei den
kleinsten sei die regierung beschloss
schulklassen unbedingt geöffnet zu
lassen auch bei positiv fällen müssen
kinder sich auf testen lassen oder sich
selber testen zu hause
sagen so geht es nicht weiter in seiner
klasse gab es heute fünf fälle ich lebe
in ständiger sorge dass er es bekommt
aber ohne symptome und so meine
bekannten ansteckt man muss drei
selbsttests macher am tag des kontakts
und zwei und vier tage später aber ich
bin keine krankenschwester und tests bei
kindern zu machen ist kompliziert
die tests sind ätzend für mich muss ich
wieder anmachen andauernd das wird
setzen
neue quarantine regeln und test
vorschriften treiben lehrer und eltern
gemeinsam auf die straße
wir haben den schulbetrieb nicht die
nötigen mittel um die gesundheitsregeln
vernünftig umzusetzen wir haben schon im
normalbetrieb zu wenig mittel und jetzt
kommen von oben herab immer neue
anweisungen als wäre das sofort
umsetzbar aber das ist es nicht
proteste von lehrern und eltern wenige
wochen vor einer wahl die regierung
reagiert wie sie oft auf proteste
reagiert mit materiellen zugeständnissen
wir verteilen 5 millionen ffb zwei
masken in den schulen um den bedarf zu
decken und wir stellen 3300 außer dass
lehrer zusätzlich ein hochaktuelles auch
beim theater dede sahen spielt der staat
eine hauptrolle wie bei so vielen
unternehmen des landes frankreichs
wirtschaft kommt gut durch die krise die
arbeitslosigkeit liegt auf niedrigem
niveau auch hier musste niemand
entlassen werden
wir haben natürlich hilfen bekommen
kurzarbeiter geld für die angestellten
des theaters und es gab ausgleich für
umsatzverlust
immer kaum hat die krise beruhigen und
sich soziale konfrontationen ersparen
können indem er massiv gelder verteilt
und gewissermaßen seine haushaltspolitik
im vergleich zu beginn seiner amtszeit
korrigiert hat
auch in den krankenhäusern hat sich die
regierung frieden erkauft mit mehr geld
für intensivbetten und gehaltserhöhungen
das hat mediziner beschwichtigt die
oftmals strengere maßnahmen für die
bevölkerung gefordert hatten omikron hat
sie an den rand geführt aber nicht
darüber hinaus die zahl der intensiv
fälle sinkt neuerdings
hier geht es auch um politik wir haben
bald präsidentschaftswahlen ich denke
ein neuer lockdown wäre da wohl nicht
gut angekommen zudem greift omikron die
menschen weniger an es gibt weniger
schwere fälle der modefotografie weniger
schwere fälle das käme einem mann sie
entgegen den das teatro de san gerne
aufs korn nimmt
wir werden seit fast fünf jahren von
einer präsidentin regiert der ein
intellektueller überflieger ist der
kleine makro hat einen kopf wie der
philosoph 19 da drinnen ist alles schön
geordnet ich weiß nicht wie sie ihn
sehen aber ich denke man kann weist
praktisch alles und alles andere was er
bestimmt auch
nicht nur das theater die düsen arbeitet
sich an immanuel makro ab zuletzt wurde
der kritisiert weil er gesagt hatte er
wolle ungeimpften richtig auf den sack
gehen
man kann sich über diese burschikose
ausdrucksweise auf revidiert aber ich
stehe dazu das land ist gespalten
wenn einige sich freiheit aufs banner
schreiben und die eigentlich eine
unverantwortlichkeit ist dann gefährden
sie nicht nur das leben der anderen
sondern schränken auch deren freiheit
und macau liegt nach seiner
parlamentsmehrheit verschärft die regeln
ungeimpfte können kaum mehr am
öffentlichen leben teilhaben nach all
den auseinandersetzungen zeichnet sich
langsam eine trendwende ab
das schlimmste scheint bald überstanden
der rückgang hat begonnen der höhepunkt
der infektionen ist seit einer woche in
der region paris überschritten und in
den anderen regionen des landes wohl
etwas später
mit seinem krisenmanagement hat der
präsident viel riskiert wenige wochen
vor der wahl würde das upload von
omikron marco sehr helfen
im moment kann man sagen dass der
präsident in der öffentlichen meinung
ganz gut weg
heute sieht es ganz gut für ihn hasse
aber das kann auch schnell umschlagen
der ausstieg aus einer krise ist immer
heikel
im theater der düsen fällt an diesem
abend der vorhang schlussapplaus ob die
franzosen demnächst ihrem präsidenten
applaudieren hängt auch davon ab ob
omikron wirklich von der bühne abtritt
[Musik]